bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 78 lactu
nouvelle édition en direct à 18h voici
les titres de ce journal 3 ans et demi
de travaux et de procédures et une
réouverture prévue après la toussin
l'école Victor Hugo clés sousbois va
rouvrir les parents ont déjà eu
l'occasion de la visiter avec leurs
enfants le Secours populaire des
Yvelines qui vient de se réunir en
congrès constate une popérisation des
personnes âgées et des mères
célibataires nous en parlerons avec le
secrétaire général dans les Yvelines
Pascal Rodier pour la 2e édition de
cette tournée à travers l'Hexagone de
dence Trophy des sélections étit
organisé parmi des danseurs
d'associations d'écoles de danse
d'amateurs de semiprofessionnel ou
encore de candidat libres c'était à
plaisir ce weekend parmi les juré vous
l'avez vu la chorégraphe miiafraay
célèbre pour ses participations à des
émissions de télééalité
l'image du jour une maison en paille et
en bois ce n'est pas une histoire tirée
d'un compte pour enfant elle est bien
réelle et héberge au quotidien la
famille bonau située à d-ierre elle se
distingue des réalisations actuelles par
son côté 100 % écologique 50 € par mois
pour chauffer 120 m² ou encore recyclage
de l'eau grâce à une terrasse
végétalisée une maison passive dont les
matériaux sont issus d'ailleurs de la
région elle vient de remporter la
dernière édition du concours organisé
par l'agence locale de maîtrise de
l'énergie coût total 240000 € la famille
bonau a aussi dû mettre la main à la
patte l'école Victor Hugo je vous le
disais au clés sousbois avait été
incendié en avril 2010 il aura fallu 3
ans et demi de procédures et de travaux
pour que finalement elle ouvre à nouveau
une journée portes ouvertes était
organisé d'ailleurs à la veille des
vacances de la toussin Catherine zulato
et Antony rche pour les
images c'est au son de la fanfare que
parents et enfants ont pu découvrir la
nouvelle école Victor Hugo au clés
sousbois salle de classe cantine B
bibliothèque tout a été refait et ben
elle est magnifique franchement je la
préfère plutôt qu'avant tout a changé ma
salle de classe elle est bien avant on
était dans des ALG et là B on est dans
une vraie classe on a des chaises on a
un vidéo projecteur je suis content
Mohamed et ses copains vont donc quitter
les algco de l'école Jean jores qui les
a accueillis pendant la fermeture du
groupe scolaire Victor Hugo c'était en
avril 2 10 à la suite d'un incendie
c'est un soulagement pour tout le monde
les locaux ils sont ils sont lumineux
ils sont bien insonorisés ils respectent
bien toutes les demandes qu'on avait
faites donc globalement on est très
satisfait on a hâte de s'installer
dedans une grande joie parce que c'était
un événement qui était particulièrement
attendu et on tourne la page on tourne
la page d'une histoire bien triste avec
cet incendie criminel d'une école pour
en ouvrir une autre 3 ans an de travaux
une longue reconstruction entre enquête
de police discussion avec les assurances
désamientage retard et puis la mauvaise
surprise d'un départ inattendu de
l'entreprise de gros œuvres cet été un
budget de 4,7 million d'euros supporté
par la commune nous n'avons pas d'aide
si ce n'est malheureusement uniquement
les remboursements d'assurance qui se
sont portés à 2 million d'euros mais le
coût de cette opération c'est pas
uniquement l'investissement mais
l'hébergement de l'ensemble de toutes
les classes depuis l'incendie de de 2010
avec tous les frais de fonctionnement
liés aux algeo au transport de car donc
c'est effectivement une certaine
difficulté mais c'est un choix que nous
assumons la ville a également dépensé
près de 300000 € supplémentaires par an
pour assurer notamment le transport des
enfants du quartier un quartier qui va
bénéficier aussi d'autres travaux de
rénovation la création d'une air de jeu
et d'un terrain de foot synthétique
c'est donc un nouveau départ réouverture
officielle de l'école à la fin des
vacances de la
toussin une précarité était en Hae chez
les seniors et les mères célibataires
c'est le constat du Secours populaire
des ivelines à l'issue de son congrès la
semaine dernière bonsoir Pascal Rodier
bonsoir vous êtes le secrétaire général
du Secours populaire dans le département
des ivelines lorsque vous parlez de
cette hausse de cette précarité des
mères célibataires chez les seiors
également dans quelle proportion il faut
l'entendre est-ce que la situation
aujourd'hui est dramatique inquiétante
dramatique je c'est c'est difficile de
d'utiliser ces mot là c'est toujours
dramatique pour les gens qui fréquentent
ces qui fréquentent les per d'accueil du
scours populaire puisque quand on en
vient dans une association de solidarité
pour avoir une aide pour payer ses
factures ou simplement manger euh on est
déjà dans une un contexte dramatique ce
que l'on constate par la la précarité
saisie dans nos permanences d'accueil
c'est que il y a quand même plus de 30 %
des foyers accueillis inscrits au
Secours populaire qui sont des foyers
monoparentaux ce qui représente quand
même une grosse proportion c'était pas
le cas encore l'année dernière parce
qu'on a le senti que chaque année cette
proportion augmente et que d'année en
année justement vous alertez vous et les
autres associations sur ces ces
difficultés rencontré par les mèes
célibataires et les personnes âgé aussi
oui alors en fait ce que ce qu'il y a
c'est que c'est aussi pour nous pour ce
qui concerne notre association c'est
aussi parce qu'on se développe il y a il
y a aussi parce qu'on développe des
structures que mécaniquement ça fait une
pauvreté saisie ou connu qui s'accroit
dans nos bilans dire vous dire comme ça
la pauvreté s'accroit dans les Yvelines
je intellectuellement j'aurais un peu de
mal à à vous garantir le le sujet ce que
l'on voit par contre effectivement ce
qui est nouveau depuis maintenant 4 5
ans quand même c'est une une progression
et un ressenti qui était déjà dans
l'esprit des bénévoles et qui est
confirmé dans les statistique c'est que
on a quand même un nombre relativement
important de seniors puisque j'avais
noté le voilà on a à peu près plus de on
a un petit peu plus de 10 % du public
qui a plus de 60 ans et ça il y a 4 5
ans en fait on ne voyait pas à cette
proportion là et comment ça s'explique
alors cette évolution est-ce qu'il y a
une explication à donner contexte
économique difficile des retraites trop
faible précarisation des parcours
professionnel qui fait que en fait de
plus en plus les gens ont pas leur
trimestre et sont au minima de la de la
retraite SCU en fait et quand vous êtes
sur des périodes de votre vie où vous
n'avez pu travailler où les indemnités
ont baissé ça fait que par exemple vous
n'avez pas pu accéder à la propriété
vous restez locataire donc avec des ch
financièr qui sont pas pareil quand vous
avez payé et puis les loyers qui
continuent à augmenter et voilà il faut
toujours le payer alors qu'en général
quand on arrive à la retraite on est
plutôt quand on a pu être propriétaire
c'est ça vie exctement en fait il faut
avoir la chance de pouvoir accéder à la
propriété déjà avant 40 ans sinon après
ça se complique fortement et il y a
aussi je pense alors ça c'est un constat
un peu patientifique mais que que l'on
mesure comme ça c'est l'éclatement des
structures familiales complique aussi
euh à des rebonds aussi bien dans les
les les âges les plus jeunes pour les
enfants que sur les générations
auudessus parce que quand la famille
devient monoparentale souvent on
enclenche une solidarité familiale les
parents des parents donc nos aînés sont
souvent mis à contribution et tout ça
tend les budgets de un peu de tout le
monde quoi et quelle quelle évolution
peut imaginz parce que là vous offrez
une solution ces familles viennent vous
voir vous vous le dites vous développez
vos services donc de plus en plus de
personnes viennent vous voir mais est-ce
qu'on peut imaginer une amélioration
aussi est-ce que vous alertez aussi les
pouvoirs publics sur ces questions-là
alors bah nous euh si vous voulez ce que
l'on dit dans les instances
représentatives au niveau national et
par nos bilans on a de cesse d'alerter
sur laacroissement de la pauvreté
constaté dans nos permanences d'accueil
encore une fois avec les réserves qu'on
peut peut-être faire lié au à
l'accroissement du nombre de structures
qui fait qu'il y a plus de de précarité
saisie ou constaté hein euh mais tous
les indicateurs sont là au-delà du
Secours populaire pour dire que les
l'écart entre les plus riches et les
plus pauvres se s croit avec les
nouvelles règles de calcul des retraites
je pense que ça va compliqué pour de
plus en plus de monde puisque si on
rentre le plus tard sur le marché du
travail qu'on fractionne sa carrière et
qu'on doit partir plus tard sans compter
les problèmes de santé les accidents de
la vie comme on dit
euh ça va ça va se compliquer et il y a
des choses qui sont pas forcément que du
du ressort du politique et qui sont
peut-être aussi un peu des évolutions
sociales ou sociétales les éclatements
de famille on sat sans faire de jugement
de valeur sur les familles et leur
compositions on sait que en règle
générale pour les femmes ça crée un une
popérisation un appauvrissement
mécanique aujourd'hui vous accueillez
1600 familles dans 21 centres un petit
peu plus maintenant combien de personnes
vous accueillez euh ça fait un peu plus
de 5600 personnes accueillis donc ça
c'est le nombre de personnes voilà donc
ça fait dans les
1700 1700 familles avec des fois des
familles très nombreuses donc nous en
fait on les on les accroî on considère
que en fait ça reviendrait à presque
2000 familles de taille normale si on
peut dire de taille médian en fait donc
aux environs tro TR qu personnes si on
convertit ça vous fait 1900 familles
mais techniquement on a 1700 familles et
ça c'est j'insiste un peu c'est
peut-être les gens vont trouver que je
suis répétitif mais c'est la c'est la
précarité saisie il y a toute une
précarité ponctuelle que l'on oui voilà
les gens qui qui on va dire aussi osent
venir vous voir osent rencontrer les
bénévoles de de votre association mais
qui en revanche il existe une franche de
la population qui n'ose pas il y a ça
c'est ça que vous appelez la population
non saisie oui et puis il y a aussi des
gens qui sont un petit peu en
indélicatesse administrative on va dire
qu'on renseigne pas forcément dans les
fichiers pour des raisons ben pour des
raison de discrétion et il y a aussi des
gens qui
viennent de manière très ponctuel et qui
ne souhait pas se s'inscrire dans dans
une aide prolongée qu'on va voir une
fois deux fois dans l'année et cela bah
forcément on va pas non plus enclencher
tout un processus de de de traitement
statistique sans pour rentrer dans les
statistiques quand vous parlez de ces
personnes en délicatesse avec
l'administration ces personnes on va
dire sans papier pour être très clair
elles sont nombreuses est-ce que vous
constatez aussi parce que ça fait partie
des constats que vous avez dressé cette
année avec le Congrès c'est la FL
demandur d' ai c'est nouveau en fait
alors ceux-là sont en situation
régulière les les demandeurs d'asile
faut pas pas pas confondre les gens qui
ont épuisé les recours et qui du coup
sont en
situation de séjour illégal sur le
territoire et puis il y a les gens qui
font valoir des droits et les demandeurs
d'asile on a une grosse augmentation qui
est liée en fait à une embolisation
complète des structures d'accueil sur
Paris et la petite couronne et c'est un
public qu'on voit arriver dans les
ivelines avant le le département était
relativement épargné ou préservé enfin
les termes sont un peu enfin je voudrais
pas qu'on pense que c'est une gêne
mais sur sur les hôtels proches de
coignère Laverrière trappe et lancour on
a un public relativement conséquent qui
qui arrivve souvent des pays de l'Est en
fait du Kazakhstan de de tchenéie des
d'horizons un peu diverses comme ça avec
des gens qui font ce qu'ils peuvent
aussi pour bah pour s'insérer pour
apprendre le français qui qui qui n nous
aident aussi qui font du bénévolat j'ai
reçu une famille avec la la jeune fille
qui fait l'interprète pour ses parents
et le papa suit des cours de français il
souhaite faire du bénévolat pour
améliorer sa maîtrise de la langue ça
c'est des choses en fait qui sont un peu
nouvelles et qui parfois posent des
problèmes mécaniques d'adaptation quand
vous doublez la la demande sur une
structure on on a des grosses
difficultés à faire face quoi j'aimerais
juste ouvrir une parenthèse l à
l'actualité ça ne concerne pas
directement les Evelin mais ça concerne
l'ensemble du pays puisque cette affaire
n'en finit plus de de faire parler c'est
l'expulsion de leonarda quel regard vous
avez est-ce que vous avez un regard
est-ce que vous vous prononcez sur cette
question là je préfère pas me prononcer
parce que en fait c'est une situation
qui est complètement enfin on on nous
dit des choses au fur et à mesure il y a
une enquête administrative ben comme
toutes les enquêtes administratives
c'est l'administration qui l'a fait donc
c'est relativement neutre et au regard
de l'application strict du droit VO les
lycéens qui sont Mobil
VO le droit ou la justice et l'équité
sans rentrer pour un sujet de philo pour
nos nos jeunes lycéen le il y a une
différence entre la justice et l'équité
ce qui pourrait paraître équitable peut
ne pas être permis par la loi et ce qui
est permis par la loi certaines
personnes trouvent que c'est inéquitable
donc moi je je renvoie les les États à
leurs contradiction euh et les personnes
aussi c'est-à-dire que au bout d'un
moment c'est vrai que si vous êtes dans
des dans des logiques de
de de de de contrevérité et puis que
vous enclenchez votre famille dans des
logiques comme ça qui sont à la marge de
tout ben forcément ça complique tout
hein dès que vous êtes sur les marges
euh vous prenez un cahier les marges
c'est au bord du cahier hein donc si
vous êtes sur la marche vous risquez de
de chuter quoi donc c'est c'est terrible
par
contre moi j'ai enfin j'ai des enfants
n'importe qui qui est un peu humain se
faire humainement effectivement
humainement ça reste ça reste choquant
quoi on va marquer une petite pause avec
notre question du jour et cette question
selon vous la pauvreté concerne quel
type de population quelle population
serait la plus toucher selon vous pour
faire écho la discussion que nous avions
tout à l'heure et puis on revient
ensuite en plateau pour continuer à
parler de l'actualité du Secours
populaire pardon alors mon avis à moi
pour moi c'est plutôt les jeunes parce
que avec la difficulté de trouver un
travail aujourd'hui la difficulté de
pouvoir s'en sortir sur le marché les
études qu'on nous demande de faire donc
les jobs étudiants qui sont difficiles à
trouver et cetera je pense que ça touche
plus les jeunes après j'ai pas de de
chiffres de chiffres en tête mais ouais
je pense que toutes les toutes les
tranches d'âge doivent être touché de
toute façon catégorie sociale c'est les
étudiants et les chômeurs bien sûr je
pense les étudiants les jeunes les
personnes qui sont pas de travail ou
pourquoi les étudiants parce qu'ils
travaillent pas ils sont à l'école parce
qu'en général les retraites sont pas
très élevées il y a beaucoup de
femmes seul
qui n'ont qu'une seule retraite donc qui
doent subvenir à leurs besoins qui n'ont
pas tout toujours un logement voilà ça
doit être équivalent à mon avis pourquoi
pourquoi pour les ressources diminué
d'un côté et de l'autre bah les
étudiants n'ont pas beaucoup de
ressources ils ont de plus en plus de
mal à trouver des jobs et puis les
personnes agé ont des retraite qui sont
diminué par rapport à leur salaire
auparavant ce qui revient le plus
souvent tout de même ce sont les
étudiant on pense tout de suite aux
jeunes des jeunes ent difficultés on
pense moins au senior oui donc bah ça
fait partie des population qui
sociologiquement de de enfin déjà sont
souvent plus discrètes et deviennent
invisibles on a en règle générale hein
je veux pas non plus hormis ceux qui
font du bénévola au Secours populaire ou
dans d'autres associations mais je le
dis en souriant mais en même temps c'est
sérieux souvent pour des des personnes
qui ont quitté la vie professionnelle on
se désanonymise en faisant du du
bénévolat et le la grosse difficulté
pour les personnes âgé c'est que souvent
c'est un isolement euh physique social
qui limite aussi euh la la perception
par les travailleurs sociaux il y a une
réticence aussi et puis euh c'est une
question de dignité je veux dire si vous
avez travailler élever des enfants que
vous arrivez à un âge mû et que vous
vous vous subissez le fait d'avoir à
vous adresser à une structure pour
pouvoir manger ou faire des activités
sociales culturelles partir en vacances
mais quelle quelle dégradation de de
l'image personnelle ça peut représenter
c'est terrible en fait don qu' se
manifeste pas et pourtant leur
difficultés sont réel vous parliez du
bénévolat c'est peut-être l'occasion
aussi de rappeler que vos structures
sont ouvertes au bénévolent ah oui ah
oui plus que jamais sur qu'on arrive en
période de fin d'année que vos activités
vont se multiplier aussi bien de par
l'hiver qu' aussi par ces périodes de
fête de fin d'année puisqu'il faut
penser à tous en cette période de fête
donc en fait on a des activités de
solidarité matérielle qui qui vont se
déployer avec un libre service de Noël
qui qui touche l'ensemble des familles
qui sont sur aidé au niveau alimentaire
toute l'année on leur donne un côté
festif donc il faut multiplier les
collectes matérielles et aussi les
collectes financières c'est pour ça
qu'on fait des paquets cadeaux euh dans
la l'enseigne Fnac sur véisi 2 et sur
chamboursi maintenant on rayonne sur sur
deux structures donc on fait un large
appel au au bénévolat parce que ça ça
prend beaucoup de temps et d'énergie et
plus on est nombreux et moins c'est
pénible h à faire et ça nous permet
quand même de combler sacrément les les
budgets et de pouvoir dépenser quand
même euh quelques quelques milliers
d'euros euh à cette période-là pour
faire en sorte que Noël se passe le le
le mieux possible pour les personnes en
difficulté cette année
euh on souhaite justement être cohérent
avec nos constats et on va organiser
aussi euh pour la première fois euh un
repas de solidarité au moment des fêtes
de fin d'année pour les personnes âgées
isolées justement euh on veut leur
proposer quelque chose de beau et
quelque chose dont ils pourront se
souvenir et qu' pouront partager on est
en train de voir pour organiser un repas
sur un bateau mouche à Paris enfin
quelque chose qui les bénévoles n'hésite
pas à vous contacter pour venir vous
aider sur la ville nouvelle il y a CIN
structures il y a de la place CIN
structures plus le siège départemental
il y a de la place pour s'occuper merci
à vous merci Pascal r d'être venue sur
ce plateau responsable du Secours
populaire des ivelines on va parler
santé à présent un futur centre de
médecine gériatrique qui va voir le jour
à Plaisir la première pierre vient
d'être posée pour l'été 2015 la
construction de ce centre accueillera
les patients de médecine gériatrique
polyvalente et psychogériatrie cognitive
en hospitalisation complète en
hospitalisation de jour et en
consultation toutes les précisions avec
ce
reportage élu professionnels de la santé
chacun à leur tour il participe à la
pose de la première pierre du futur
centre de médecine gériatrique le
bâtiment constituera la troisème partie
de l'hôpital gérontologique et
médico-social
plaisir il y aura 144 lit à la fois du
court séjour donc des des personnes
âgées qui restent assez peu de temps 20
30 jours et cetera du soin de suite et
réadaptation gériatrique et
également des hôpitaux plus enfin des
unités plus spécialisées vers les
troubles neurocognitifs et cetera c'est
un transfert des des lits que vous voyez
dans le bâtiment qui est derrière le
bâtiment qui est derrière sera
totalement ou partiellement désaffecté
les objectifs principau du transfert
développer la partie consultation mais
aussi la partie technique avec
l'implantation d'un nouveau scanner pour
la ville de plaisir c'est aussi une
architecture plus moderne bah ça c'est
un pas vers l'avenir je dirais ça va
s'ouvrir en 2015 2015 c'est demain on
est déjà je veux dire aux portes de
2014-25 c'est une vraie modernité au
centre au centre même de la ville de
plaisir on est vraiment privilégié par
rapport à ça l'accueil ne serait-ce que
du terrain quand vous voyez c'est un
grand parc donc en plus les médecins
rappelai la qualité le confort la
confiance qu'on peut y attendre pour la
ville de plaisir c'est un plus coût
total de l'opération 28 millions d'euros
financé par l'hôpital de plaisir et par
des crédit de l'agence régionale de
santé le bâtiment sera livré dans 2
ans culture la 2e édition du Concours
National d'enstophy France 2013 a fité
qu'Al la plaisir pour cette épreuve des
danseurs non professionnels se sont
affrontés dans dans la catégorie danse
de salon et danse contemporaine le jury
composé de la chorégraphe américaine
miafraay sélectionne le meilleur de
chaque catégorie pour représenter la
région en novembre prochain avec une
grande finale nationale rencontre avec
les candidats en catégorie danse
contemporaine et yolen Torz Antony
Resche c'est leur tout premier concours
habitué au spectacle ces troupe venu
tout droit d'Orly se mesure pour la
première fois à d'autres candidats lors
d'une véritable compétition la 2eme
édition du dan
profil on n a poussé aussi à repousser
nos limites d'une certaine façon parce
que de se dire que c'est la première
fois qu'on va danser devant devant un
jury en fait et que ce soit personnalité
ou pas ça nous ça nous donne envie de
montrer ce qu'on veut et de se dépasser
encore plus que lorsque des spectacles
par exemple c'est aussi une question de
partage en fait on voulait faire savoir
aux G untitu ce qu'on faisait et dans
quelle spécialité et afin de nous
représenter tout simplement Johanna elle
fait partie des RAR candidate à danser
en solo à 16 ans elle a déjà 10 ans de
pratique derrière elle danse moderne
jazz Hipop ou encore danse classique
cette étudiante desen sait tout
faire grande chorégraphe américaine prés
J de dance Trophy cette année forcément
Johanna a écouté son avis avec grande
attention m'a dit que que j'é une vraie
danseuse que ça lui plaisait beaucoup
que les ont aimé aussi et ça m'a fait
plaisir c'est un peu un grand nom de la
danse et ça fait plaisir qu'il quelun
comme ça dans dans le et ce grand nom de
la danse a été surprise par la diversité
des danse proposé mais aussi par la
qualité disons que le niveau là est très
fort il y a beaucoup plus de groupe j'ai
l'impression qu'ils sont venus pour en
découdre et donc il avait vraiment bien
préparé leur numéos effectivement on
voit que c'est sans doute une région où
les gens aiment vraiment danser et
où o les adolescents comme ça il
s'exprime donc en numéro
2 c'est Joanna
maledon Joë Joan
Malon une vraie danseuse très forte
cétait puissance que tu as fait et tu es
sur le podium avec un autre groupe qui
ont tout donné aussi donc il y a pas de
problème ils ont déchiré aussi donc
crois-moi tu es avec du niveau c'est no
crew prochaine étape pour les candidats
sélectionné la finale nationale à
Bordeaux le 2 novembre prochain les
danseurs ont encore un peu de temps
devant eux pour s'entraîner sans oublier
les bons conseil de la professionnelle
prendre conscience de de de de du public
des juges qui les observe qui et de nous
inclure systématiquement au sein même de
leur chorégraphie donc le regard et
l'interprétation ce weekend avait lieu
le 3è challenge poker de 50 ans en evel
c'est à Manil le tournoi qui a réuni
près de 150 joueurs et ses bénéfices
étai dédiés à des associations
caritatives c'était pour la bonne cause
reportage Olivier manisalco
Antony allez une dame une dame une dame
une
dame
commeulian juju qui touche une suite sur
la dernière carte servie ils étaient
environ 150 ce weekend à vibrer au 3è
challenge poker de 51 eneline et les
émotions justement c'est en partie ce
que viennent chercher les joueurs c'est
juste pour s'amuser et puis avoir
quelques sensations se prendre un petit
peu pour un
professionnel enfin bon des fois c'est
c'est moins drôle quand on perd quand on
gagne c'est très amusant lunette noir
casquette vissé sur la tête et porteon
en tout genre le folklore du poker s'est
emparé du gymnase Chantal modoui de
manilamo arrivé en France il y a une
dizaine d'années le jeu continue de
séduire les joueurs et ce quel que soi
leurs origines ça mélange de tout il y a
de la stratégie des mathématiques a de
la psychologie et puis bah la chance un
petit peu aussi qui rentre qui rentre en
ligne de compte et puis le fait aussi
d'avoir desah des gens on rencontre des
gens de toute origine et de tout tout
corps de métier donc c'est des gens qu'
a peut-être pas qui serai jamais
rencontré qu'on rencontre autour d'une
table et je trouve ça relativement
agréable en plus de procurer du plaisir
et des sensations le tournoi été
organisé pour la bonne cause via le prix
des inscriptions et les buvettes près de
1000 € ont pu être récolté pour des
associations manquoises la MEC
humanitaire et vivre au
village
FL on redécouvre l'image du jour si vous
n'étiez pas avec nous au début de cette
édition une maison en paille et en bois
ce n'est pas une histoire tirée d'un
compte pour enfants elle est bien réelle
et elle héberge au quotidien la famille
Bono est située à dpierre cette maison
passive a remporter la dernière dernière
édition du concours organisé par
l'agence locale de maîtrise de l'énergie
coou total de cette construction 240000
€ mais la famille bonau a aussi mis la
main à la patte c'est la fin de ce
journal à retrouver en replay sur notre
site internet je vous retrouve mardi en
direct à 18h avec Olivier de laaporte
conseiller général pour évoquer la
politique du département vers les
personnes âgées dans le cadre de la
Semaine bleue et puis bien sûr
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale bonne
soirée ce lundi soir vous avez
rendez-vous avec Anthony rche pour le 78
sport